[Música]
qué pasa cuando algo se rompe
la plancha no prende el costo de la
tostadora no se traba cuando lo bajas la
campera aceite de escocés el celular no
puede actualizarse y entonces
básicamente queda obsoleto son historias
tan comunes como tristes
y si ustedes son como yo cuando un
objeto se le rompe lo que hacen es
ponerlo en un rincón de sus casas como
si fuera una nota mental de que vamos a
ocuparnos de reparar este objeto
y entonces lo que pasa es que pasan
muchos meses meses en los que por alguna
razón no logramos ni siquiera empezar a
veces no sabemos a dónde llevarlos no
tenemos tiempo de ocuparnos
sospechamos que repararlos puede costar
más caro que comprar los nuevos
pero a la vez nos da pena tirar los
dejamos hay una voz del sentido común
que nos dice que no puede estar bien
descartar todo un aparato por una
pequeña falla
y a la vez muchos de nosotros tenemos
este registro este recuerdo de que antes
las cosas duraban más tiempo no mi mamá
por ejemplo tuvo una heladera que te
duró más de 30 años y a mí me cuesta
muchísimo que un celular me dure más de
y esta dificultad para reparar las cosas
es más que una sensación encontramos con
que muchos de los aparatos que tenemos
hoy no tienen tornillos a la vista por
ejemplo están sellados no podemos ni
siquiera abrirlos no conseguimos
repuestos los fabricantes nos dejan
completamente solos el día después del
final de la garantía
básicamente vemos que hay muchos objetos
que no están diseñados para poder ser
reparados
y tampoco están diseñados para poder ser
reciclados
básicamente muchas de las cosas que
consumimos hoy no están hechas pensando
en su ciclo de vida completo
y esto es un problema de diseño pero a
la vez no es accidental no es una mala
praxis de un diseñador
responde a una estrategia
responde un modelo de consumo que surge
alrededor de la década del 30
en el cual básicamente se propuso
intentar resolver una recesión a través
de un modelo de consumo lineal de
crecimiento ilimitado
y para lograr esto era necesario que
hubiera mucha demanda demanda en
permanente crecimiento
y sostenida en el tiempo
y para lograr esta demanda un poco
apareció este concepto de
deliberadamente acotar la vida útil de
las cosas de diseñar las cosas a
propósito con una fecha de vencimiento
determinada en objetos que por ahí antes
no la tenían
objetos empezaron a ser diseñados para
no poder ser reparados para tener que
descartarse y reemplazarse o incluso
para ser percibidos como objetos
obsoletos y generar una sensación de que
es necesario re cambiarlos es lo que
conocemos como obsolescencia programada
y más o menos alrededor de la misma
época apareció otra idea desopilante que
fue la idea de lo descartable la idea de
que ítems que antes teníamos uno y
duraba para toda la vida de golpe podían
volverse artículos que usábamos una sola
vez y tirábamos con esta libertad
y esta idea un poco se presentó como una
manera en la que podíamos ahorrarnos
tiempo y esfuerzo
comodidad practicidad ya no hace falta
todo este trabajo de lavar cuidar un
objeto devolverlo envases retornables
reutilizar las cosas repararlas para que
duren más tiempo
y esta idea de lo descartable con el
correr de los años un poco se aplicó a
muchísimas cosas muchísimas cosas de
nuestra vida cotidiana funcionan con
esta lógica
y en definitiva nos permiten ahorrarnos
tiempo no podemos ahorrarnos el tiempo
de tener que lavar un cubierto
reutilizable y podemos usarlo
descartarle y tirarlo podemos ahorrarnos
el tiempo de tener que lavar y cortar
una verdura a nosotros mismos que ya
viene en un envase biodegradable
bastante perfecto que conocemos como
cáscara
y también podemos ahorrarnos el tiempo
de tener que encontrar la manera de
reparar algo que se rompe porque en
definitiva tal vez va a resultar más
barato reemplazarlo por uno nuevo
el tema es que si bien todas estas cosas
hoy tal vez nos ahorran algo de tiempo
la pregunta es estamos ahorrando tiempo
a costa de qué
y lo que resulta que sucede es que un
poco hay costos que no están entrando en
la ecuación como que hay mucho que no
vemos
quienes vivimos en ciudades por ejemplo
en general no vemos cómo es la
extracción de recursos naturales con los
que están hechas las cosas
tampoco vemos cómo son las condiciones
de trabajo en la que personas producen
esas cosas que compramos
y tampoco vemos cómo es esa disposición
final a dónde van a parar todas esas
cosas que nosotros descartamos como que
todo esto sucede muy lejos de nosotros
y nosotros no siempre somos conscientes
de esto a veces para nosotros es como si
las cosas nacieran en una góndola y
desaparecieron de la faz del planeta el
día que la sacamos de nuestras casas
pero el punto es que no estamos pagando
el costo real que tiene este consumo hay
un impacto que no estamos que no estamos
contemplando en la ecuación
y está un poco es un problema hoy
sabemos que tenemos un problema
sabemos que estamos generando una
cantidad de residuos absolutamente
desmedida a una velocidad muy grande y
lo cierto es que no sabemos todavía muy
bien cómo resolverlo en distintos
lugares del mundo se acumulan montañas
de residuos que todavía no sabemos muy
bien cómo vamos a tratar
y a la vez sabemos también que estamos
consumiendo recursos naturales a una
velocidad mucho mayor a la que tardan en
regenerarse
también todo este consumo implica
demanda de energía que también impacta
sobre el ambiente
y un poco hay un consenso científico
bastante amplio de que esto es
insostenible
es una situación de desequilibrio
pero a la vez la sensación es que no
estamos reaccionando pareciera que nada
cambia o sea ya sabemos que esto es así
y aún así pareciera que todo sigue igual
y creo que ante problemas como este no
sé cómo se sienten ustedes pero yo suelo
sentirme muy angustiada y frustrada muy
pequeña e impotente
y a veces incluso resignada
y para muchos de ustedes piensan que
claramente un problema como este no se
excede o sea recae por encima de
nosotros
y sin duda gran parte de la
responsabilidad por este problema recae
en los fabricantes y en los gobiernos
sin duda necesitamos leyes que obliguen
a los fabricantes básicamente a estar
las cosas bien
a pensar en el ciclo de vida completo de
sus productos a tratar de regenerar los
recursos naturales que consumen y
también hacerse cargo de los residuos
que resultan de sus productos
lamentablemente todas estas leyes no
estarían sucediendo a la velocidad a la
que los necesitamos
nuestros legisladores no estarían
reaccionando y las empresas que producen
estos objetos tampoco estarían
reaccionando ante una oportunidad de ser
responsables de actuar de una manera
responsable con el ambiente
y frente a problemas como este siento
que siempre caemos como en una especie
de círculo vicioso donde pareciera que
la responsabilidad rueda y no termina de
caer en ningún lado no es como que
nosotros no podemos ser consumidores más
responsables porque muchas veces no
tenemos opciones
y a la vez los fabricantes no tienen
mucha curva en ofrecernos mejores
alternativas ni hay leyes que los
obliguen a hacerlo porque lo cierto es
que tampoco pareciera haber una masa
crítica de consumidores que lo estemos
demandando
entonces cómo se sale de este círculo
vicioso y tal vez una manera sea que
todos asumamos como un rol de mayor
responsabilidad responsabilidad por
aquello que si nos toca no porque si lo
piensan en definitiva para los
fabricantes
el cliente somos nosotros
y para legisladores el votante somos
nosotros con lo cual tal vez tengamos un
poder bastante mayor al que nos damos
cuenta para para pensar en de qué manera
podemos empezar a generar un cambio
frente a este modelo
y creo que hay mucho que si podemos
hacer
y por lo pronto creo que esto lo resume
bastante bien
en las palabras de vivienne westwood que
dijo comprar menos elegir bien y hacerlo
durar
y comprar menos tiene que ver con
hacernos muchas más preguntas antes de
comprar algo realmente cuestionar si lo
que vamos a comprar es realmente
necesario si es realmente necesario
pensar si hay que comprarlo si podemos
resolverlo de alguna otra manera por ahí
podemos compartir alquilar
y elegir bien tiene que ver con
investigar hacer un trabajo de
investigación antes de comprar algo
tratar de elegir a marcas que estén
haciendo las cosas lo mejor posible
elegir cosas que estén diseñadas para
durar cosas que puedan repararse
hacerlo durar tiene que ver con cuidar
las cosas valorar los recursos en las
cosas y realmente hacer todo el esfuerzo
que está a nuestro alcance para que
duren el mayor tiempo posible reparar
las cosas cuando se rompen podemos
recurrir a nuestros reparadores del
barrio que son una especie millo
invisibilizada casi en vías de extinción
pero que están ahí y que muchas veces
pueden dar una solución a las cosas que
se rompen
y cuando no pueden dar una solución hay
muchas otras alternativas podemos buscar
tutoriales en internet hay miles podemos
pasar un sábado intentando aprender algo
nuevo podemos pedir ayuda a amigos o
familiares que se den un poco más de
maña que nosotros también es importante
compartir públicamente nuestra
frustración cuando no logramos preparar
algo y cuando si lo logramos hoy las
marcas tienen redes podemos hablarles
podemos pedirles mejores productos
y también podemos pensar en asumir algún
tipo de activismo algún rol de activismo
que puede ser un activismo full time o
un activismo party
o incluso una crisis freelance en sus
ratos libres
pero creo que todos desde el lugar que
cada uno ocupa no seamos diseñadores o
ingenieros periodistas maestros si ellos
de alguna empresa de consumo masivo
todos de alguna manera podemos
contribuir y ser parte de la solución
y hace tres años junto con medina scioli
un poco sentimos este impulso de hacer
algo de intentar alguna forma de
activismo
nosotros no somos técnicas ni somos
reparadoras expertas
un rubro somos más bien comunicadoras y
emprendedoras y entusiastas fervientes e
inspiradas en proyectos que conocimos
que existían en otras partes del mundo
como repair café o restart
se nos ocurrió y quisimos intentar esta
idea de crear un encuentro de reparación
colectiva
es una idea que al principio ni nosotras
mismas sabíamos muy bien cómo iba a
funcionar
pero la idea del síntesis era simple y
consistía en crear un espacio un
encuentro al cual convocamos a personas
con distintos saberes de reparación
personas que supieran mucho poquito nada
macgyver urgente que se da manha gente
curiosa intrépida valiente que le gusta
intentar abrir un aparato y encontrar
dónde está el problema junto con objetos
rotos y personas con ganas de agregar la
vida útil de sus cosas y también con
bastante mate y algunas cosas ricas
y un poco así generamos un primer
encuentro al cual vinieron un montón de
personas y en el que logramos reparar un
montón de objetos muchos más de los que
nos hubiésemos imaginado de hecho
y un poco a partir de ahí nació este
proyecto que llamamos club de
reparadores que hoy es un movimiento que
impulsamos junto a julia tea morosoli y
un grupo increíble de personas
y que un poco busca resignificar la
reparación
en este sentido sustentable que tiene en
el sentido de que implica alargar la
vida útil de las cosas y de esa manera
valorar los recursos
pensamos en reparar como una manera de
aprender cómo funcionan las cosas de
entender un poco más de vincularnos
desde otro lugar con las cosas que
tenemos
y un poco la premisa también es que
reparar adjuntos o reparar con otros
siempre es más fácil y más tiene más
chances de éxito que reparar solos hay
muchas reparaciones que a una
obsolescencia mediante son bastante
posibles si tenemos al lado a la
herramienta correcta y a la partida una
persona que lo haya hecho antes y que
básicamente nos dé ánimo para intentarlo
y además sucede que muchas veces
algo puede resultar más caro reparar que
reemplazar
porque la ecuación económica está rota
pero eso no significa que esa reparación
sea imposible y entonces en espacios
donde la colaboración puede dar
respuesta a esa reparación podemos
lograr reparar un montón de objetos que
por ahí no tendrían una solución por
otra vía
también desde la reparación nos pusimos
a pensar cómo es nuestra relación con
aquellas cosas que son imperfectas que
por ahí están
estuvieron dañadas y fueron reparadas y
que muestran algún tipo de cicatriz como
nos relacionamos con un parche o con una
con una reparación imperfecta y como eso
y ese acto de habernos involucrado en
reparar ese objeto puede convertirlo en
algo incluso más lindo y más valioso que
un objeto nuevo
y también pensamos en como el acto de
ponernos nosotros a reparar nosotros
mismos las cosas de alguna manera nos
reivindica como dueños de nuestros
objetos en vez de como simples usuarios
o rehenes de los fabricantes
y la verdad es que reparar cosas hoy es
re difícil los desafíos son enormes
efectivamente muchas cosas están
diseñadas para que sea muy difícil
repararlas
y muchas veces requiere el trabajo de
varias personas y varias horas de
dedicación y aún así a veces no lo
logramos pero muchas otras veces si lo
logramos
y esas veces que lo logramos y esa
sensación de lograr preparar un objeto
es una sensación de triunfo y de
victoria que realmente les recomiendo es
es como una sensación muy enorme es casi
desproporcionada es como que va mucho
más allá del objeto que reparamos
es casi como una victoria frente a todo
este modelo de consumo que no solo
sabemos que no es sostenible sino que
también empezamos a sospechar que
tampoco nos hace tan felices
y club de reparadores está por cumplir
tres años en los que organizamos más de
45 encuentros de reparación
en más de tres provincias de argentina y
más de diez encuentros en uruguay y por
estos encuentros pasaron casi tres mil
personas y logramos reparar más de 2.000
objetos
y si bien son números que nos
enorgullece en un montón
si miramos este impacto en términos
cuantitativos no es gigante nos estamos
moviendo la aguja
y resolviendo este problema
pero si lo miramos en términos
cualitativos si pensamos en cada una de
las personas que pasó por el club y en
las historias detrás de cada uno de esos
objetos que reparamos ahí si sentimos
que el impacto que tenemos es mucho más
valioso y también quizás si hubiese
muchísimos más clubes de reparadores o
encuentros de reparación
no solo lograríamos prevenir una
cantidad enorme de residuos y reparar
muchas más cosas sino que también
lograríamos crear una masa crítica mayor
de consumidores responsables que no
estamos dispuestos a resignarnos y
seguir descartando sin parar las cosas
[Música]
ahí hay veces que nos escribe gente al
club de reparadores y nos pregunta y que
reparan
y es una pregunta que nosotros también
nos hacemos
y a veces nos preguntamos si estamos
reparando planchas y minipimer si
auriculares o será que lo que estamos
reparando de alguna manera pasa por otro
lado
y creemos que tal vez más importante aún
que reparar los objetos en sí
o sea la idea de reparar nuestra
relación con las cosas y de esa manera
reparar también nuestra relación con los
recursos naturales y con las personas
[Aplausos]
[Música]